so our neighbors to the north are
clearly losing it the prime minister who
needs a history lesson and a haircut has
declared war on canadian citizens like
they're an isis caliphate
emergency powers freezing bank accounts
and threatening to take away protesters
dogs and children dana perino is very
upset
it's getting so bad up there government
forces are even targeting innocent
gelato shops like this one here in
ottawa canada turns out the owner of
stellaluna cafe made a giant mistake
she privately supported the freedom
truckers convoy
with a 250 donation
her donation then leaked and was made
public her gelato shop was then doxed
and began receiving threats lunatics
threatening her with violence and
vandalism
treating her like a salem witch
all because she showed her support for
freedom
the owner of stellaluna gelato cafe
tammy giuliani no relation to rudy
is here with us now
all right tammy what exactly is going on
up there with your shop
well
i should preface by saying that i have a
tendency to think with my heart and not
with my head
and does that get me in trouble a lot
and would i change that about myself not
in a million years
um and when i heard about a group of
people that were willing to drive all
the way across the country and below 30
weather
to gather peacefully in front of
parliament and to stand up for their
beliefs and to
say you know maybe this whole mandating
the existence out of everyone needs to
be revisited
my heart said no and i don't think
anyone and i certainly don't think um
anyone could have imagined that it would
have transformed into something like
we're witnessing today
yeah we're witnessing complete chaos and
i don't know how to describe it
but you probably know him better than i
do since you're up there
what has been the blowback for you and
your shop and what kind of threats and
harassment have you faced after that
donation was made public
well you need to understand that stella
luna is our livelihood and my husband
and our children and son-in-law all work
for the business it's how we pay our
rent it's how we keep our lights on it's
how we eat
um so
we feel very passionately about eating
and um
everyone has pushed really hard over the
past two years trying to keep this
business alive so
we have uh this this passion and it just
keeps going on and on so i reached into
my personal pocket and i pulled out 250
bucks of my personal money and i gave a
donation to fill a gas tank of someone
so they didn't have to sleep in -30 in
the cold that night and i think that
decision speaks to my humanity
and not to political beliefs
but attacking our children
attacking our team um that's
unconscionable and i think never in my
56 years have i ever experienced
a country
so divided
um so full of hatred towards friends and
neighbors
sorry lost
so full of hatred towards their friends
of neighbors um you know they might have
opinions that differ from theirs but
they're so willing to publicly shame and
humiliate and spew forth angry
um
you know we have been called uh
terrorists for the first 60 36 hours we
were inundated with hatred with threats
of violence um people threatened our
team on the phone telling them we're
coming to get you
we're going to throw bricks through your
window you'll pay for this you nazi
supporter
i personally have been called a
disgusting pig of a woman and that i
should rot in hell
our
rural shop out in merrickville ontario
someone draped a large bed sheet
over our sign
i'm sorry it's been it's been a tough
few days and i think
you know and the sign read tammy
supports terrorists um
now mama bear is gonna dig out her claws
on that one and uh we're getting the
video surveillance and uh the incident
and we will pursue
uh that with the police but um
late yesterday afternoon messages of
support and encouragement started to
arrive and people from coast to coast to
coast
throughout canada
and the us
and um you know they've been buying gift
cards online
and calling themselves uh
guardian angels
um so
you know we're gonna use those funds to
help pay the staff for their missed
shifts and get some security guards in
and make sure everybody's safe and that
they feel safe coming to work
but the phone has been ringing off the
hook all day today from calls all over
canada
all over the u.s
sharing stories of losing their jobs uh
because of bankruptcy or
because they refuse to get vaccinated um
losing their homes
you know
we've heard uh tragic stories yes i
didn't think it was going to be this
hard
but we
i understand
um you know heard so many stories from
people calling
to support us because you know
we're pretty insignificant and
we're just a little gelato shop
and all we want to do is make really
good gelato
and so to have our
you know to be targeted and have our
staff targeted and our children targeted
because i decided to reach in my pocket
and you know fill the gas can of some
guy i didn't want to see sleep in the
cold overnight
um you know but our kids arrived at the
shop today and there were heart-shaped
balloons hanging from the door handle
and the window was covered with
um little sticky notes and um they were
all these inspirational messages of
encouragement i think our favorite
which sums it up in a nutshell so to
speak
was somebody said pistachios before
politics
that's wonderful well tammy you are such
a
perfect person
i love you i i the audience loves you
you're a total sweetheart i i can see
how hard this has been for you but how
inspiring
you've been for us and for the community
up there and we're at jesse waters prime
time we're going to order a boatload of
pistachio i don't care how we get it
here we're going to get it here and
we're going to order a hell of a lot of
it so
you know keep up the good fight
yes one one message i want to leave
people with and
truly thank you so much for everyone for
all over for for contributing buying
gift cards um but
we think
we all need a healthy dose of positivity
and love and respect and we all need a
whole lot less judgment and hate
and i think if people would um just
before they open their mouth or they
start tapping away on their keyboards
if they could just listen to their heart
and find their humanity the world would
be better served
well said
tammy for prime minister of canada i
think it starts right here thank you so
much tammy you're the best
that was very very moving and we support
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else